hey what's up my name is Jared and you
guessed it I'm a DJ that's cents that's
a remix that we're gonna make hey how's
it going I'm chase I'm 25 and I'm
holding a fish why am i holding this
fish who knows hi I'm miles I'm 24 and
I'm a self-proclaimed male feminist even
though I secretly troll women online and
body shame them when they reject me on
tinder hi I'm Ernesto and I'm a fairly
normal guy but full disclosure I am
latin-american so we have a reputation
for being Mama's boys but that's
entirely not true
I'm a no no no my mom says that she's
looking forward to meeting you hello my
name is Richard and before I used to be
super into material things but ever
since I took a spiritual journey to
Tulum I'm a completely changed man it
was three of the best days of my life oh
hey I'm bullet we used to date oh my god
wait
you